the european union is so far the biggest  donor of safe and effective covet 19  vaccines  as team europe we have exceeded our  vaccine sharing target in 2021  we have promised to share 250 million  doses with low and middle income  countries by the end of 2021  and in fact we shared  380 million doses mostly through covax  more than 255 million of these doses are  already delivered to the recipient  countries  and of course we will do more  team europe has promised to share  700 million doses by mid mid-2022  we are on track to fulfill this promise  and in particular we will step up our  efforts to support africa where  vaccination rates are lower than in  other parts of the world  because we will only control this global  pandemic  if we fight it in every corner of the  world